[Music]
in the lush rainforests of Australia
birds roost in the low branches and
amble across the forest floor enjoying
the shade and tropical fruits but the
jungle isn't theirs alone a dingo is
prowling in the shadows and fruit won't
satisfy his appetite
the birds nests safety all but the
cassowary who can't clear the ground on
her puny wings instead she attacks
sending the dingo running for cover
with one swipe of her razor-sharp claws
the cassowary is one of approximately
sixty living species of flightless birds
these earthbound avians live all over
the world from the Australian outback to
the African savannah to Antarctic shores
they include some species of duck and
all species of penguin secretive swamp
dwellers and speedy ostriches giant emus
and tiny Kiwis though the common
ancestor of all modern birds could fly
many different bird species have
independently lost their flight flight
can have incredible benefits especially
for escaping predators hunting and
traveling long distances but it also has
high costs it consumes huge amounts of
energy and limits body size and weight a
bird that doesn't fly conserves energy
so it may be able to survive on a
scarcer or less nutrient-rich food
source than one that flies the taça hae
of New Zealand for example lives almost
entirely on the soft base of alpine
grasses for birds that nest or feed on
the ground this predisposition to
flightlessness can be even stronger when
a bird species doesn't face specific
pressures to fly it can stop flying in
as quickly as a few generations then
over thousands or millions of years the
bird's bodies change to match this new
behavior their bones once hollow to
minimize weight become dense their
sturdy feathers turned to fluff their
wings shrink and in some cases disappear
entirely and the keel like protrusion on
their sternums where the flight muscles
attach shrinks or dis
piers except in penguins who repurpose
their flight muscles and heels for
swimming
most often flightlessness evolves after
a bird species flies to an island where
there are no predators as long as these
predator free circumstances last the
birds thrive but they are vulnerable to
changes in their environment for
instance human settlers bring dogs cats
and stowaway rodents to islands these
animals often prey on flightless birds
and can drive them to extinction in New
Zealand stokes introduced by european
settlers have threatened many native
species of flightless bird some have
gone extinct while others are endangered
so in spite of the energy-saving
advantages of flightlessness many
flightless bird species have only a
short run before going the way of the
dodo but a few flightless birds have
survived on mainland's alongside
predators aplenty
unlike most small flightless species
that come and go quickly these Giants
have been flightless for tens of
millions of years their ancestors
appeared around the same time as the
first small mammals and they were
probably able to survive because they
were evolving and growing at the same
time as their mammalian predators most
of these birds like emus and ostriches
ballooned in size weighing hundreds of
pounds more than wings can lift their
legs grew thick their feet sturdy and
newly developed by muscles turned them
into formidable runners though they no
longer use them to fly many of these
birds repurpose their wings for other
means they can be spotted tucking their
heads beneath them for warmth flashing
them at prospective mates sheltering
eggs with them or even using them to
steer as they charge across the plains
they may be flightless but they're still
winging it did you know that a brown
thrasher knows a thousand songs or that
a wood thrush can sing two pitches at
once find out how birds learn to sing
their songs with this episode
[Music]